of all the Elder Scrolls games
why was Skyrim the one chosen to get the
remaster treatment
why not oblivion or even morrowind well
Podesta has a pretty good answer
I'm Lucy and welcome to you're
struggling to avoid the obvious arrow to
the knee joke GameSpot news update
but there's the marketing boss Pete
Hines told GameSpot that the work that
would go into a remaster of oblivion
would be better used towards a brand new
game he explained oblivion is 10 years
old so the amount of work for that
engine and that tech to bring it and
remaster it and do all the things we
wanted to do was significant it's not
impossible but it was mountainous it was
either like go make an entire new game
or do Skyrim Hines reminded us that the
development team had already ported
Skyrim to the Xbox one as a technical
exercise so some of the work had already
been done it just seemed to be a much
closer path it was the most successful
game that we had ever done before
fallout 4 so it already had a huge
audience Hines also explained how Skyrim
mod support would work on both PC and
consoles the idea is that it's exactly
the same way as fallout for Skyrim
special edition on pc is free only if
you own Skyrim and all the DLC it also
has a new creation kit it doesn't just
work with all of the existing mods they
will have to take that mod and run it
through the new creation kit and publish
it to Bethesda net then that would be
available on consoles after the Skyrim
remasters reveal at e3 Hines was asked
if old mods would work with the new
version of the game he answered that
basically yes they would and that the
remastered PC version would be 64-bit so
any mods running at 32-bit would have to
be modified to be compatible mine said
the pastor will continue to work on and
evolve mods on fallout 4 but those
improvements will also make their way to
Skyrim he added that aside from mods the
Skyrim remaster won't feature new quests
or content
he said systems wise and content wise
it's the game plus all of the DLC
so are you excited for Skyrim special
edition or are you still wishing it was
oblivion instead let me know in the
comments below or come find me on
Twitter I'm at Lucy James games for more
Elder Scrolls goodness make sure you
keep it GameSpot